there is safety in the shadows for this
young zimbabwean
his name is tawanda mucheowa and he's
been hiding for months
in an unlit corner of a large african
city
there are many times whereby i cry
but you know it's some more at some
moments you feel like you are crying in
the dark
and no one is seeing your tears in july
machiawa was abducted and tortured for
three successive days
it was an ordeal that nearly killed him
now he wants to bring those responsible
to justice
my abduction is one in a thousand
and something must be done to
stop the zimbabwean government
the 22 year old was sitting in a car in
front of this shop
in the city of bulawayo when a group of
men
thought to be members of the security
services seized him
and stuffed him in the back of a pickup
truck
he says he was driven out of town and
tortured
and sexually abused for the following 72
hours
it's an experience that will never leave
him someday you feel like you're not
okay
then the other day you're breaking down
the other day i'm shaking
so you know it's now sort of my life now
it's like a roller coaster it's ups and
downs
so i'm so traumatized i think i can say
human rights lawyers say dozens of
government critics and activists
have been abducted in the last few years
but this
alleged abduction was caught on cctv
the camera even capturing a license
plate belonging to one of the team
members
involved the government they know
exactly who abducted me
they know the perpetrators they know the
people who are involved
they have all the details in black and
white
the vehicle registration on the pickup
was traced to a car rental company
called impala
and activists have called on the firm to
release the name of the person who
rented it
but impala refused
so this group locked the company's staff
in their office in protest
the head of zimbabwe's student union has
also called on impala to release the
information
but he was attacked by unknown
assailants when he attempted to hold a
press conference
muchella has also tried to get the name
obtaining an order from the high court
which instructed impala to provide it
but in this letter the company says the
zimbabwean police
has already taken the relevant files
sharif went there to collect the
documents and impala said
they no longer have the documents you
know it's just so ridiculous
how can a company like impala failed to
have
maybe some backup copies of that
information
you know that your car was used to
commit a crime against humanity
which is a climate international law
sky news has discovered that the man who
runs impala
thompson dondo is a fugitive from
british justice
he ran a nursing agency in the uk but
left the country
after he was charged with immigration
offences
in a statement cleveland police told us
if he attempted to re-enter the uk
he would be placed before the courts in
response
a spokesperson for impala said his court
case dragged on for more than
13 months he legally left the uk as he
had no means to sustain his livelihood
has the abduction radicalized you
three days of being tortured
three days not knowing what is going to
happen to you
people discussing about how they are
going to kill you you know in a way it
really changes your mind
and i think in my case i think it made
me to
see that you know there is nothing to
live for
if you don't have freedom the government
has not commented on claims made by
tawanda macheowa
although it's accused people of faking
such incidents
in return for western funds and they're
proposing legislation
criminalizing those who make allegations
of abductions and torture
but this 22 year old exile will not be
silenced
john sparks sky news